euren freunden und freundinnen
beschreiben
meine damen
ja der wunsch
planet spielen werden erstelle deinen
movistar ja ich glaube jetzt einfach mal
auf zufälliger junge erstellten exakt
der sieht genau so aus wie ich hier
drücken mal wieder auf zufälliger junge
und schauen was diesmal bei ja ich trage
auch immer eine sporthose aber dann ein
hemd ich hab mich jetzt einfach mal so
erstellte er sieht mir glaube ich am
ähnlichsten das heißt wir klicken jetzt
auf ok fertig und ich muss mich erst mal
neu anmelden eigentlich habe ich schon
movistar playground weil ich habe es
halt auch schon mal auf einem kanal
hochgeladen
allerdings wurde mein account gesperrt
weil ich in meinem video leute beleidigt
habe und angeblich zu alt für das spiel
bin ich bin ein star
viele fanden kaka wie sein name ist
nicht erlaubt wollt ihr mich verarschen
[Musik]
bei elefanten willkommen bei movistar
planet lauda sieht umwerfend aus ja
danke kann man von dir nicht so
behaupten dass elefanten aa habt spaß
alles klar dass ich das letzte mal
movies tablett auf meinem kanal gespielt
habe ist bereits zwei jahre her von
daher weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau
wie ich mich hier zurechtfinden soll
wir haben auf jeden fall verschiedene
kategorien und zwar spiele movie town
chat shopping und haustiere das heißt
wir gehen erst mal in den jets haben
jetzt alle verschiedene orte und zwar
das café den strand einkaufszentrum
bleibe aber gleich wird sagen wir gehen
mal am strand der sich am meisten bock
drauf hier sind jetzt andere leute auch
alles klar die gal weiterhin chancen
sehe ich aus wie mein rechter fuß ticker
bevor wir der januar jede nachricht
schicken können müssen wir gleich mit
der befreundet sein das heißt wir warten
jetzt einfach mal ab
ich schicke mal nach dem check eine
freundschaftsanfrage ja genau ich
brauche erstmal ein paar freunde
das topmodell wie ip
[Musik]
ich wollte von der kamera weg gehen und
so zeigen wie ip wer braucht denn sowas
da habe ich mir selbst ins auge
gestochen tut ein bisschen weh ist so in
der pflanze sind das alles sachen die
die sich gekauft hat sich verstehe gar
nicht mehr was hier abgeht ich glaube
ich kann hier unten auch in sachen
machen ja genau ich kann winken
ich kann auch hochspringen ich kann
tanzen
dass das hat uns mal lieber sein der
einfach ein verdammtes pferd degas also
der strand ist ein bisschen suspekt
geworden und daher würde ich sagen den
wir jetzt einfach mal ins café hier rein
my life ball steht wirklich in jedem
café auf der speisekarte der jetzt
gerade mal 10 15 leuten
freundschaftsanfragen geschickt haben
hier oben ist jetzt nur eins bei den
freunden das heißt ja panik möchte dein
freund sein
ich werde nicht pushen aber ich habe
jetzt meine freunde gewinnt also mit der
japan
wenn ich jetzt befreundet das heißt ich
denke einfach mal auf die drauf kann
nicht da denn jetzt eine nachricht
schreiben ich weiß ja das funktioniert
wie sehe ich aus wie da kann ich nicht
schreiben ich kann die mülltonne stecken
nach einer beziehung fragen
ich stehe jetzt auch mal hier unten
drauf da kann ich mit der japaner in
einen raum gehen in japan i gleich
kommen sie direkt meine sinken dance
musst du siehst aus wie mein rechter fuß
elefanten also so will japan die auf
jeden fall mit ihrer beziehung sein
[Gelächter]
das ist ja gar nicht japan ist die stern
die 980 setzen den raum hier gegangen
ich würde sagen dann stellt man mit der
er zwar ein bisschen hey ich habe keine
ahnung ob diese stern die 89 englisch
wenn die 89 geborene seine sie 30 jahre
alte gut und der also sie ist
anscheinend deutsch
das heißt als nächstes schreibe ich ihr
einfach mal ich bin elefanten wer bist
du
ich weiß wie smalltalk sorry hab ein
freund ich find dich eh nicht so hübsch
ja ja ich verstehe so jungs glaub mir
mein charakter tanz
online ich kann auch an alle jede
nachricht schicken ich stimmte nach
elefantenkuh verpasst sich direkt einmal
nicht selbst sieht man mal auf den paul
drauf der gerade meinte ich gehe seiner
freundin hinterher mdr ist zusammen mit
die honey 89 egoist sein status an der
stelle wird das häufig videos allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde
movistar planet es auf jeden fall mega
mega lustiges game liebes movistar team
falls dieses video hier sehen sollte
bitte hat meinen account nicht ich
möchte noch ein weiteres video von hohen
laden ist es sogar jeder darf sich dort
wieder blockiert werden
[Musik]